would you kiss shut about that don't
scream at the children don't scream at
the children hey guys I'm Ryan Wright
and I'm Katie Dubois we could check out
from top five unknowns five most
disturbing found footage videos to ever
be released in this list we look at some
rather disturbing videos that belong to
killers and lunatics so sure that were
released to the public not all of these
are home videos we've also included some
CCTV footage number 5 I know Jane Lea
slivko tapes this deranged maniac was a
serial killer from the Soviet Union
between 1964 and 1985 he murdered seven
boys between the ages of 7 and 17 the
man was truly twisted in 1961 at the age
of 21 slivko witnessed a horrific
traffic accident in which a boy wearing
a Boy Scout uniform was killed he said
that the brutality of the scene sexually
excited him during the same time of the
accident slivko worked at a boys club
and began to exploit his position there
once or twice a year
he would get the children to reenact the
accident he would also get the children
to partake in an experiment that he had
invented he would hang the children
upside down wait until they became
unconscious then would revive them while
they were unconscious he would perform
horrific acts on them during some of the
experiments he became violent once the
victims were unconscious
he would dismember their bodies then set
them on fire to remind himself of the
traffic accident the police finally
caught him after a lengthy investigation
into a missing persons case he was
sentenced to death on seven counts of
murder sexual abuse in
philia he was executed on the 16th of
september 1989 by a gunshot to the head
when police searched his home they found
several videotapes it turns out the sick
individual filmed all the experiments he
had done now of course I'm not going to
show the gruesome parts but they are
available on the web
number four Robert Pickton prison cell
tapes Robert Pickton is a Canadian
serial killer and form a
multi-millionaire pig farmer he is
believed to have murdered 49 women from
1983 to 2002 though he was only charged
with 26 he killed most of his victims in
his slaughterhouse and within feebler
remains to his pigs this even lived hell
casuals issuing a tainted reel morning
to customers who bought pork that came
from his farm he was eventually caught
by the police after a series of events
in 1997 he tried to murder a prostitute
who he took back to his farm she told
the police up Robert had handcuffed her
that stabbed her several times with a
knife she managed to escape he was
charged with the attempted murder of the
prostitute but was later released after
this police kept a close eye on him the
police then notice that woman who
visited his farm would go missing the
police then searched his farm in 2002 he
was charged with 26 counts of murder
after the police had found human remains
while excavating his farm he was
sentenced to life in prison with no
possibility of parole for 25 years while
in jail an undercover officer was put in
his cell to act as an inmate in order to
get information out of him this is what
was found on a CCTV footage of his cell
it's pretty disturbing hearing the way
he described he with dispose of the
bodies
number three
Columbine home movies most of you
probably know what horrific event
Columbine was but for those that don't
it was a mass shooting that cut at
Columbine High School in Colorado on
April 20th 1999 the shooters were two
senior students at the school Eric
Harris and Dylan Klebold as well as the
shootings they placed bombs in the
cafeteria 99 explosive devices and bomb
bricked cars around the school
they killed 12 students and one teacher
and then killed themselves they also
injured 21 people their motives for the
attack remains unclear but home videos
were found at their homes which may give
an insight into their madness these are
not the Columbine basement tapes in
which we've discussed in a previous
video these are different home movies
and summer school projects it's pretty
creepy watching them knowing what they
were planning look I don't care what you
say if you ever touch him again I will
freaking kill you my boy got him shotgun
and blow your damn head off do you
understand you little worthless piece of
crap number two geez
Ricardo Bjork stalker Ricardo Lopez
otherwise known as the Bjork stalker was
an American purse control officer who
attempted to kill Icelandic singer björk
in September 1996 in 1993 Ricardo became
upset
with the singer I grew increasingly
angry over her relationship with
musician Goldie within a nine-month
period Riccardo made a video diary at
his apartment in them he talked about
pure can many other strange topics
towards of the final videos he began to
show himself making a letter bomb which
is rigged with sulfuric acid in which he
descend into Bjork's home in London he
sent the bomb to try to kill or
disfigure the singer on September 12th
1996 he made a video of him going to the
post office to send a bomb off he later
returned home and committed suicide on
camera police discovered his decomposing
body four days later and also found his
video diary of the viewing for tapes
they were able to intercept the bomb
that was in the mail Ricardo's plan was
how hopefully the bomb would kill Bjork
then as he committed suicide there would
be United in heaven now I won't show the
suicide but I will show the moments
right before it number 1 Columbine CCTV
tapes
once again Columbine makes the list this
time it's of the CCTV footage of what
took place in the cafeteria the original
footage is three hours long but have cut
it down into parts in which events take
place Oh students are weary as they
could hear gunfire and possibly some
explosions then teachers and security
told the students to evacuate the school
and this is when panic sets in soon
after this students begin to calm down
and some hide on the tables and teachers
and security walk through a small
explosion is then seen surely after this
the dust settles from the explosion and
there is a small amount of movement from
the students teachers and security then
come back running through the cafeteria
as if they are running away then there's
two more explosions after this Eric and
Dylan are seen as they both walk through
the cafeteria and then begin to start
shooting then Dylan throw something and
it explodes and starts a fire after this
Eric and Dylan both leave then another
explosion occurs which causes a file
the shooters venom
on and off camera a few times they then
leave once again surely after they
killed themselves
thank you so much for watching be sure
to check out our other videos and don't
forget to subscribe to keep updated with
us good bye a little videos until you
subscribe like that [ __ ] oh wow now I'm
like so depressed
oh that's just oh god don't hurt people
don't hurt people man thanks Ryan
you're welcome I mean I've seen so many
like dark videos lately that if you're
like I'm becoming immune to how dark
some of these videos are I'm not immune
yet the first guy who would abduct I
mean he would like that's terrifying to
know like he would infiltrate like Boy
Scouts well he was already in the Boy
Scouts oh yeah I know the M&E victims
were there right right that's scary he's
a lot of Boy Scouts out there said today
you know like they put a lot of faith in
these leaders they have the old worse
then a lot of those leaders are great
awesome people but this guy was crazy at
first I was like oh this is interesting
a car crash is what caused him to be
this way but then you hear that it's
sexually excited him yeah I mean he's
already broken person yeah there was
something before that car crash that
really triggered these actions that he
took upon yeah I could have been
anything that you know something six
months from that accident could have
triggered it oh god I can only imagine
him I like if I would not get a sexual
excitement at all I saw that car crash
no of course not I mean if it was like a
woman in a bikini with big tits and she
came out of the car alive no damage and
was like walking around like beautiful
like oh please carry me to safety and
then I will will yeah exactly
okay but that's like a word that in a
dare or onra I know this is called
reality fair that's fair Robert Pickton
them must inspire the Hannibal words of
the lands yeah because the guy is there
at the pig farm like killing people
yeah it must have been a reference well
in Hannibal Gary Oldman's character did
specifically that he would kill that
people would die then you feed them
eggs clever idea I didn't know FBI
undercover about whatever would actually
do that sometimes like imposter or
prisoner yeah I think other that's
clever as a great way to get confessions
out of people I mean you're giving a hot
illegal you would think that will be
illegal right maybe maybe it has
something else like he's already been
sentenced and now they're just trying to
understand mm-hmm or something or maybe
there's a copycat feeding body parts the
pigs I mean oh it's like for an insane
serial killer smart way to get rid of
them but just from a moral standpoint
good job for that prostitute for
escaping though the prostitute is glad
yeah to the arrest yeah you know yeah
escape somehow even though she was
handcuffed a good job her I've never
killed anyone but I've had many
prostitutes in my life escape I didn't
try to kill them they saw that picture
of my penis and they just a fled they
fled and I would run after me like no it
was a bad picture that day it was off
it's always the black prostitutes
they're the number one prostitute I
ain't and eight dot I'm not racist I
want a black prostitute of God what
drives that psychology exactly like I I
want these videos to kind of go into
that just a little bit maybe not loggers
I just wanted to serve you with the
facts but I always find it interesting
to hear how someone developed into that
like Ted Bundy said that it started with
him discovering graphic pornography like
hardcore graphic pornography when he was
a boy and that's what like started him
so like there are triggers for people
yeah but then I still think you have to
be messed up like you still have to do
some kind of mental disorder yeah some
kind of psychopathy
well it's crazier the call Mike Evans
it's not one person it was feels yeah so
it's like they've ten people with mental
disorder yeah it's like be that that's
so is when it's one person it's easier
to be like there must be a mental
disorder but when it's two people I'm
like there's got to be some deep
psychology and play here if two people
were willing to bond over this and go
through it right yeah I know when I was
really young I must have been like eight
years old
was this cart this Highway Patrol chase
I was watching this car chase and then
this guy had a shock and what he did was
he put out this banner he just laid out
this banner on the freeway he was
carrying a shotgun so no one was like
[ __ ] with the guy
the cameraman tried pulling away and he
blew his head off and I was like eight
years old no no that the camera was in
the helicopter he tried pulling away but
I was like eight years old this was live
TV live oh yeah the guy blew his head
off yeah I would have been so horrified
I know it day I would have been
horrified no I mean and it makes me
wonder cuz like there is a strong period
of time when I was writing a lot of
stories and I took interest in like
trial I'm nowhere near the lines of
being a serial killer but when I saw but
I would like learn about serial killers
and stuff for characters it was
fascinating to me I don't know if that
played a part of my life of being
fascinated with violence so I think it's
at a certain age we all sort of got like
I was fascinated with the Titanic yeah
who's everyone dying that's like I think
you kind of have to learn how to process
stuff and like Mastiffs and like
horrifying circumstances yeah but there
are people most people learn how to
process that mm-hmm right these people
not so much
I haven't thought about that guy's head
being blown off look like ever just let
it just lock it up put it away just
denial is the only way to truly deal
with your problem that was one of the
most fun videos I've seen in a while
well do something happy like go go to
the circus or or strip club go outside
and look at the bunny ranch the one
legal brothel in the u.s. hats horn
plays them puppies I was a terrible
terribly upsetting video xvideos calm if
you can't afford to go out thanks for
tuning in to the channel for new to it
you can subscribe to the real rejects
and feel the rejection um well I don't
know what to say guys just to just put a
bunch of comments what I should say calm
or reject or get a do pod on the cage
blah channel get yo dick to pod that
sounds like I'm telling people
jerk off to you um don't I don't like
wait dumb she doesn't like penis I just
haven't had enough of accidental penis
for the day okay I said that every day